is an expert in she was one of the early
movers we decided that simulation and
chemistry were so I think the format of
this morning's talks differ slightly
than the sort of what who mesh described
as the high-level and deep dive the yin
and the yang I think of this morning's
talk are sort of good news bad news so I
told us this morning about all the
wonderful things that we expect that
quantum computers to be able to do and
I'll talk more about hardness results
and some of the limitations at least in
the theoretical sense okay so we're
talking about the local Hamiltonian
problem let me start with a definition
okay so we have a system of n qubits
qubits some finite dimensional particles
and that in a Hamiltonian term that
operates that describes the physics of
the interaction of these particles okay
and this is presented to us in this nice
compact form we have our terms each of
which operates on a small constant
number of the particles we'll call this
number K and the dimension of our
individual particles is D and it's not
too hard to arrange things so that the
we have a bounded norm of of one to each
of these terms and so along with this is
the problem definition we get two
numbers an energy and a delta and the
Delta is usually 1 over poly log
polynomial and N and the question that
we want to answer essentially what we're
asking is what's the ground energy of
this system so is there is the smallest
eigenvalue of the matrix that I get if I
add all these terms together is it less
than e or is at least a plus Delta so I
give we give ourselves a little margin
of error here with this Delta and we
want to know if it's
or above the other it's a promise
problem in that if it's in that in the
region between we don't have to answer
correctly okay
so this problem has appeal to a lot of
different groups this is a fundamental
problem in condensed matter physics a
lot of numerics of condensed matters is
solving exactly this problem with
various different types of Hamiltonian
terms different geometries of the qubits
so this has been a fundamental problem
in physics but also appeals to computer
scientists because it's essentially a
quantum version of constraint
satisfaction so if it happens that these
individual terms are all diagonal and
what we call the standard basis or the
basis defined by these qubits then this
is essentially constraint satisfaction
which is a generalization of boolean
satisfiability so it's a fundamental
problem for us as computer scientists as
well as an important problem for
physicists and as I pointed out this is
you know something that we want to be
able to solve on near term computers as
a starting point of quantum simulations
as well so a lot of different reasons
why we care about this so if it's going
to be a generalization of Sat then I
need a generalization of NP to describe
the complexity or the computational
complexity of solving this problem so it
essentially if if if all of these
matrices are diagonal its defining a
function if I set these variables to
this value that's going to be the
function each of these is a little
function on K different variables
telling you the cost of setting those
variables to a particular value and so
what I'm looking for is some global
setting of all the variables such that
the sum of the cost is as small as
possible so that's it essentially and
you can think of this even let's let's
talk about as a boolean satisfiability
problem let's see let's see these are
one zero variables each of these could
be thought of as a clause that says if I
if I set the Bulleid variables in a
certain way it's odd
Slyder it's not satisfied and I'm asking
for a global setting of all the
variables yeah so now so the basis for
this space is the the boolean cube in
general when these are general matrices
the ground state could be a
superposition but that doesn't happen in
the special case where these individual
matrices are diagonal they're all
diagonal then the optimal solution is
also going to be on that diagonal so
it'll be a classical state instead of a
quantum state sorry okay thank you
yeah so it's a it's the my the
description of my problem is polynomial
but when I put this together if I were
right to write this out this would be a
2 to the N by 2 to the n matrix okay all
right thank you
okay so NP the problem definition here
is that I have an instance which I'll
call X and we have a verifier if X is in
the language there's some type of
witness that my polynomial time verifier
can verify that it's in the language and
if it's not in the language no matter
what witness you give me the verifier is
going to reject okay
and we know that boolean satisfiability
is np-complete so the quantum version of
NP is Q MA
okay so now we're defining our verifier
as a circuit family a quantum circuit
family and if X is in the language then
now the witnesses are quantum there's
some type of quantum witness that will
cause my circuit to accept with
reasonable high probability 2/3 in this
case and if X is another language no
matter what witness you're given the
probably of acceptance is at most 1/3
and we'll talk about this but the the
punchline is that local Hamiltonian is Q
may complete so it's complete for this
class
and these probabilities can be boosted
so that they're arbitrarily close to one
and zero so for containment for a
boolean satisfiability to show that it's
an NP the witness is just the assignment
to the variables and you can then check
that into the pack this satisfies your
assignment so similarly in the qma world
we're asking is there a state that
causes the energy to be less than a
certain amount and the witness is that
state okay so I'm not going to talk too
much about containment but we need some
type of way of given a state to measure
it
so we're guaranteed that the energy is
at most some bounded by e or at least a
plus Delta and we need a way to measure
the average energy of this state so
there's a there's a circuit that can do
that and if you repeat this enough times
you can distinguish between these two
cases so it's not too hard to show the
containment the more tricky part is that
showing the hardness okay so a proof
that local Hamiltonian is QA hard starts
with some generic language in qma okay
what does it mean to be in QA it means I
have this quantum verifier that can do
this verification so here's what the
quantum verifier would look like X's
hard coded as the input and I have some
potential witness here and this circuit
will accept or reject if there's a
witness that causes it to accept or
reject so this is sort of the basic
qualification for being in QM a and now
we want to translate that or reduce that
to an instance of local Hamiltonian okay
so on the left hand side I have the
circuit that says if X is in the
language there's some witness that
causes it to accept if X is not in the
language no matter what I plug in here
the probability of acceptance is low and
I'm translating that into a
hamiltonian problem hamiltonian problem
consists of these three components the
Hamiltonian itself the bound and the
distance and so I have to translate it
into a Hamiltonian whose ground state is
less than e if X is in the language if
there is a witness that causes this
circuit to accept and the ground energy
is at least a certain amount if there's
no witness that causes it to accept and
X definitely needs to be hard-coded into
this Hamiltonian here okay and so
cations original construction showed
that the five local Hamiltonian is Q may
complete I'm not going to go through the
whole construction but I'll give you a
snapshot of what the what the ground
state looks like or what the actual
construction looks like so the ground
state of the Hamiltonian that's
constructed shows the entire history of
the the verification process so we have
two registers here here's a clock
register and here's the actual
computation register that's simulating
the computation of the circuit okay so
it's a superposition of all the
different points of time in this circuit
from zero all the way to T and I'm
assuming that I circuit has T gates okay
and it's a supervision of what the
circuit looks like at the beginning what
it looks like after one gate supplied
after two gates applied all the way up
through T and the fact that I'm
entangling each of these computation
states these snapshots of the circuit
with a clock register means that they're
not going to there's no going to be no
negative interference so it really is
sort of a an equal superposition of the
entire history of this computation and
then we need that the spectral gap is at
least a certain amount because we want
in the case that it's not accepting that
there's going to be a high energy there
are two additional components to the
Hamiltonian one locks in the input that
just basically says at time zero the the
X register needs to have the correct
input whatever I want it to be so this
induces an energy penalty if the Jace
bed is wrong
if at times zero the the contents of
this register should just have the input
to my circuit and so this says if we're
at time zero and the input is wrong
there's going to be a penalty yes
because in the event that it's in the
event that it's non accepting and
there's going to be some penalty for non
accepting I want to make sure that I'm
not cheating by by by my circuit not
being in this ground state so there's a
penalty for not being in this ground
state so that the state itself really
does have to represent the accurate
construction of the circuit
but this really is the spectral gap of
this particular Hamiltonian and I need
it to be at least a certain amount so
that so you can imagine I want to cheat
okay I want to I want to somehow get
make this ground state look like an
accepting state by not actually having
my state represent the computation
there's a penalty for that the maximum
is probably but slightly slightly
perturbed then you wouldn't have liked
to be a sister state but not from the
same witness right so we've these two
has the same except for a me this
slightly is more okay but good enough
okay that would work to know so for any
correct computation no matter so this is
just saying for you know as long as the
I'm inputting two things to my circuit X
and the witness okay and this will have
this will be in the ground state if I'm
a correct computation for that witness
whatever it happens to be whether it's
accepting or not and there's going to be
a penalty if my state doesn't represent
the correct execution of that circuit
okay okay and the final term says we
have to accept at time T at the end of
the circuit if whatever my output bit of
my circuit is if it's not accepting
that's going to introduce an energy
penalty okay and we put these together
and that's the whole Hamiltonian
construction
all right this is like a very quick
introduction to the Katai of
insurrection so I can imagine different
variations of this problem okay I'm
going to focus mostly on this sort of
the different varieties of things that
people were studied locality tells me
for each of these terms how many
different different particles each term
can operate on locality is a little bit
of a deceptive term because we associate
it with spatial locality it's really not
it's really just a mathematical concept
that says each one of these terms
operates on some number of particles it
doesn't actually refer to some embedding
in wheel space and locality okay so I
can play with the dimension of my
individual particles and I can also look
at a more physically realistic situation
in which these particles are in fact
embedded in some space we often look at
a 2d grid where the particles sit on the
vertices of the grid and we allow
interaction terms along the edges so
this picture is a to local Hamiltonian
because I have interaction terms along
each edge that I'm adding together ok so
these are the different varieties that
you can imagine studying so just to step
through some of the progress that that
has been made on this problem could I
have originally showed that five local
two-state qubits is QM a complete that
was the original proof later this was
shown to actually work in on a two
dimensional space so in two dimensions
two local and each of these individual
particles has six dimensions to it
later improved to to local to state and
then even on the grid so even if I have
qubits here it's too local it's still qm
a complete and then we came along and
actually proved that this could be
extended to the 1d line so there's a one
dimensional analog of it I'm gonna say a
little bit about this paper first and
the relationship between QM a and
adiabatic computation because they're
sort of intimately connected so I gave
us a nice intro and set us up pretty
well for adiabatic computation we're
studying and some in the ground state of
some Hamiltonian that's supposedly easy
to prepare we are coming up with some
Hamiltonian whose final ground state
encodes the answer to some computational
problem that we're interested in and
then we slowly evolve i've drawn it as a
straight line here but you could imagine
there is potentially a curved line
through hamiltonian space but this is
sort of the most natural version of just
slowly taking a convex combination of
the two hamiltonian terms okay so and as
I mentioned that the speed with which we
can travel from one to the other depends
on the spectral gap of the Hamiltonians
as we go so we were bounded we can't go
faster than the inverse of the spectral
gap as we progress from one Hamiltonian
to the other and the final measurement
then we do some final measurement to get
the the answer to our problem so we
evolve slowly to this this term if we go
slowly enough we stay in the ground
state so hopefully at the end of this
process we're sitting in the ground
state and we can measure and get an
answer to our problem so originally this
was suggested as a way of potentially
using quantum computers to solve np-hard
problems and possibly adiabatic
computation can be more robust against
certain types of errors and the question
is you know how does this relate to our
traditional circuit model what's the
what's the relationship between the two
and the quantum circuit simulate an
adiabatic computation the answer is yes
more interesting for us is can an
adiabatic computation perform anything
that a circuit can do and here the
answer is also yes and it's often
intimately connected with these qma
hardness results because the constructed
Hamiltonian looks a lot like the
propagation history state that I that we
use for the hardness results so in this
case the final Hamiltonian that we
construct is going to be equal to the
propagation Hamiltonian of the circuit
that we want to simulate so we're asking
can do it about a computation can I
simulate a circuit and get the same
answer
and so the final Hamiltonian that we
pick is exactly this the Hamiltonian
whose ground state is this history state
- the witness we're just asking for a
particular input does my circuit accept
or not so this is what the the start
state would look like all zeros easy to
prepare the final Hamiltonian is the
propagation Hamiltonian for this circuit
hopefully at the end we end up with this
history state for this circuit and to
measure we ask ok we measured the clock
state and if I'm in the last clock state
then we measure and say is the output
one so this the we only get the correct
answer when we measured the clock state
if we happen to be in the last time
period and this succeeds with probably
whatever T plus 1 so there's some
probably err but you can repeat this
polynomial number of times and get the
others years so a lot of times these QM
a complete list results sort of go hand
in hand with the with a comparable
adiabatic result and so when it was
proven that the two dimensional a local
Hamiltonian problem is Q may complete it
also had the effect of proving that you
can actually simulate this adiabatic
computation of a circuit in two
dimensions as well
okay so and we encoded the input into
the state of the circuit so there's a
little bit of extra work to show that
not just the start state and the final
state have a large spectrograph but
everything in between so so this is by
the way there the actual sort of the
matrix for the the propagation okay I
also want to say a little bit about how
we actually achieve these sort of how we
can actually get this two-dimensional
result the original kitaev construction
had a computation register and a clock
register that were conceptually quite
separate okay so we don't think of these
as existing space and then to advance
the clock where acquires of an operation
or the the clock qubits as well as the
computation bit so I'm saying if I
advance the clock then I have to apply a
gate okay so in order to this is very
non spatial because I'm grabbing some
qubits from the clock and some kids from
the computation and so in order to
actually sort of execute this in some
spatial dimension I need to actually
have the clock somehow distributed
through this two-dimensional grid and so
each particle now encodes a qubit as
well as something some encoding of a
clock and I'm using colors to denote
this so the idea is is that you have
this pattern of colors and that tells
you a clock State so I think of sort of
the computation going from left to right
as I've executing you know the the the
teeth gate
these are we've executed three steps of
the gate we have several left to go
and each column tells you the state of
the of the circuit at a particular point
in time and as we progress from left to
right the particles go from black from
yellow to black it progresses from left
to right and the clock advances so
so so this is the active column that
actually is encoding qubits and and the
Hamiltonian propagation is acting upon
two terms so the essential idea is that
we're using some locals Hamiltonian
terms to say certain patterns of colors
are forbidden and we're using certain
propagation terms to say okay I'm
applying a gate and I'm advancing the
clock in some way so the clock is
somehow represented in this pattern of
colors in this grid and the actual
mechanics of this are I won't go into
but basically you can think of a clock
state now is a pattern of colors okay
and if I look at sort of the set of
clock states I have a bunch of invalid
clock states which I've invalided by
some penalty term and these are the
actual clock States that represents the
same kind of progress through time as
the Kataya clock which was numbered 0 1
2 3 ok so we're actually just taking
that clock and distributing it to the TV
through the one-dimensional construction
is very similar but let me just say a
little bit about why the 1d result was a
little bit surprising in this context
first of all numerically businesses have
had a great deal of success finding
ground states heuristically in one
dimensions whereas 2d seems to be quite
difficult in terms of the actual
classical simulation than finding ground
states so in particular the density
matrix renormalization group method
developed by Steve wide at UCI was one
of the most successful methods that
actually using classical computers to
find ground states and was largely very
successful and then also if you look at
the classical analog the version of
constraint satisfaction where the
variables are on a line this is actually
solvable in P so the classical analog in
this case is in P whereas in 2d it's
np-complete but the difference here is
that
quantum superposition as an extra
dimension to encode the the progress of
the circuit okay so it's it's kind of a
similar construction where we have this
patterns of colors and we're moving the
the circuit through time and we're
shifting we sort of execute one gate and
then shift the qubits over and then
there's some sort of curse or qubit
that's sort of traveling around carrying
information back and forth so there's
this active site that triggers the
execution of a gate and then moves
qubits around the system so it's it's a
similar type of construction that that
accomplishes this in 1d question yes you
still need to have the number of qubits
being proportional to the depth of the
circuit right right so the number of q
particles is still n the number of
qubits in my circuit I'm simulating
times T the size I've just taken that
grid and funded out so that means if I
understand still that there are
polynomial gaps in other resource
constraints like in size and maybe in
still in some time variables because
they're Mary you still be for example a
square root speed-up in one model versus
the other one yeah so you're saying that
there may be a more efficient
construction that doesn't have this
product of the qubits times time yes and
I think in most of these sort of
spatially distributed ones you it needs
that product so you have to record it
that way so but not so in the Kataya of
construction where you just have the two
so he said this is something you can say
about you know when you when you talk
about these moving stuff around because
of course what you have is a Hamiltonian
and so can you do the translation
between you know why is it okay to think
about right and that okay so the
question so the question is we're
talking I'm talking about this dynamic
situation where I've got this particle
that's moving information around in this
process that's happening and that's the
beauty I think of the Katai of
construction is that you can take a
process a computational process and
encode it in a static circuit so much
like the way we take the process of a
Turing machine and encode it in a static
boolean satisfiability problem so you
know we can think of the circuit as
changing information through time which
is what we do and we represent all of
that in some static boolean
satisfiability problems similar here I'm
thinking of this as some process by
which there's this little cursor moving
around and moving information and such
but at the end of the day all of that is
encoded into this propagation
Hamiltonian that enforces that the
ground state is the whole movie of that
process each each frame is encoded in
the ground state so underlying all of
this we start you know sort of naturally
talking about encoding processes into
the ground state it's always that
translation of the using the propagation
Hamiltonian to translate that into the
ground state
without help yeah yeah but I was hoping
you would do it that is like okay so um
I think I actually had maybe I'll go
back
to this slide here so I want I want this
to move forward okay so I want this
cursor to somehow go from here to here
and I want to encode that in my
Hamiltonian this is the term that
doesn't okay it says that basically it
enforces the fact that before the step
is executed the amplitude of that state
has to be equal to the amplitude of the
state after the step is executed and
that's what this Hamiltonian term says
it says at time T if you're in this
state that at time T plus one you better
be in this state and if you're not
there's going to be an energy penalty to
pay so that's the sort of essential
piece that does that translation oh ok
so in the 1d case
so here's what the movie looks like I've
got the the propagation Hamiltonian only
applies to things with the red dot
that's where the action is okay so as
this red dot goes from left to right it
triggers the execution of a gate okay
and then when it gets to the end it says
oh I'm at the end I need to copy
everything over in order to process the
next row of gates so this little guy has
a lot of work to do it shuttles back and
forth copying all of this information
over and the process starts again
any more question for the two day local
Hamiltonian when you're checking if the
adjuster is ballad wouldn't I take a lot
of like a hello to do a lot of qubits to
check as it turns out you can do it with
only local terms so and there are only
so many local terms you have because
there are only n squared local terms so
I can say for example in this picture
you know the the blue has to be to the
left of the yellow the yellow has to
have a white one next to it so I can use
a small number of local terms to rule
out exponential number of terms
yes phrase you back and forth the red
yeah and those of us who have worked for
Turing machines know how painful this is
but it's kind of a similar idea so
you've got this this red state and it
has the capacity to remember a cube it
so you can encode a qubit into that
state so it it coincides with this state
it absorbs whatever the value of the
qubit is and then it moves along to the
left and plops that value here and then
does the same thing for the next qubit
so it's this cursor this little red dot
that's moving around that sort of weeds
a qubit and codes that we encode it in
its in its memory and it moves that
qubit over
yeah this reminds me a great deal of the
Mint's image machines Marvin Minsky love
this actually automata kind of thing are
they yeah he also had a tape and was
trying to find the smallest FSM that
would allow him to do the small
computations and he had to copy them
over and over like this and it turned
into a game and I was wondering if you
might be able to utilize some of the
same principles that he did because as
much of this is classical logic yes yeah
yeah so a lot of this is sort of a
classical construction and that we just
happen to be copying qubits and right so
a lot of the sort of the mechanisms of
the clock so I don't know
yes I the twelve dimensionalities to get
this or information to pass over one
another yeah and actually the dimension
le here is much higher I you know it's
twelve now and it was approved to nine
but yes you need because you're encoding
it's got to have control information
from the colors as well as potentially
encoding the qubits so that's what we're
the higher dimensionality comes from so
we don't know if this could be done with
qubits for example in 1d
do you suspect that it's true I think I
think I suspect not I think you need
some higher dimension to actually encode
of all of this control but in 2d you can
get away with qubits because you have
the spatial you can create sort of more
sophisticated yeah
yes somehow you say that for every
two-dimensional California there is one
dimensional one corresponding to each
somehow reaching the ground state is
kind of analogous so I'm taking that 2d
2d grid of computation and encoding it
in a 1d that doesn't mean that the
physics of every 2d system can be
translated into 1d we're kind of talking
on a very special class of propagation
hamiltonians for the
okay so so one of the things that makes
this particularly non-physical I mean
there are a lot of things here but one
of the particular things is that we need
kind of a special Hamiltonian at each
individual cubit of this construction
okay so it's highly non translationally
invariant whereas the typical types of
systems that a physicist might look at
are have the interaction term between
every pair is identical across you just
decide on your one model and that
describes the physics between two Navy
and qubits and it's the same across so
you could ask well what is the if I
limit myself to translationally
invariant qubits what's the complexity
there so here's the problem statement
the Hamiltonian term itself is part of
the definition of the problem okay so
that's not part of the input that's
fixed once and for all
the only input I give you is the size of
your system okay and then I ask you if
you take that Hamiltonian term and apply
it to every neighboring pair of qubits
in an N by n grid or in length and line
for example what's the lowest energy of
that system
so now the problem by the way has shrunk
the promo specification is shrunken size
usually in complexity we speak of the
running time as a function of the length
of the input so now previously my input
was proportional to the size of the
number of qubits in the system
now it's exponentially smaller I'm just
telling you the size of the system so it
turns out that this is also
computationally difficult and but we
need a slightly different complexity
class to describe it this is Q MA
I described for you before the the the
witness' sizes and the circuit families
polynomial in the number of qubits and
now I'm defining the same thing expect
except exponential time so this is an
exponential size circuit the the
witnesses are potentially exponentially
long the thing that's changed is not
that the problems gotten harder just the
inputs gotten smaller so we actually
proved in this case that it's actually
hard even in the translation invariant
case and so just to appreciate what's
happening here we have an instance X so
we're doing this reduction we're trying
to show that this problem is hard the
only way of encoding the input in this
case is translating it into the system
size okay so the Hamiltonian term is
fixed once and for all so any
information about the language itself
has to be encoded in the one Hamiltonian
finite size Hamiltonian term and so and
so in the in the reduction we take an
instance X we translate it into a system
size and we want this hardness to show
so we want this system or this
Hamiltonian problem to represent whether
X is in the language so if there's a
witness that causes X to accept then the
system has low energy and otherwise it
has high energy so thinking now in terms
of encoding these Hamilton
as processes the process that we're in
coding now has a two step first we count
the number of particles in the system
and write that number in binary on the
tape and then we execute and simulate
the verifier on that input so we first
implement a binary counting Turing
machine that just a little cursor
shuttles back and forth and counts how
many particles there are and then
encodes that count in a number that's
sitting on the tape and then we use that
number as the input to the verification
procedure so somehow we're translating
the size of the system into a string and
that string becomes the input to the to
the problem that we're trying to solve
so the the reduction is basically you
know we're executing this little binary
counting turning machine from one end of
the four n different steps where n is
the length of the system and whatever it
has sitting on that string at the end is
the input to the system and that's the
reduction
okay so any of these any I've described
it as a classical process and the first
step really is just a completely
classical touring machine and we know
that that that can be made one so and I
should say that we moved from the
circuit model to the touring quantum
Turing machine model for a reason here
and the reason is is that circuits are
big so to describe a circuit it actually
in order to describe an entire circuit
family requires a lot of space whereas
in order to describe a language using a
Turing machine I just tell you the rules
of the Turing machine and it's a finite
object which is exactly what we need
because we need to encode everything
about that language in the Hamiltonian
itself
so we need a clock that counts the
number of particles in the chain twice
and then executes so I'm gonna skip over
some of the details here and talk a
little bit more about what happens in
the thermodynamic limit so a lot of
times what physicists are interested in
not the the ground energy of actual
finite system but what does it look like
on an infinite grid okay so in our paper
we actually show that esta if if the
Hamiltonian term is viewed as part of
the input you can actually show that
estimating it to within some bit of
precision is qmax complete but once you
move to the infinite grid you actually
have the possibility of a much more
powerful hardness result which is
undecidability okay and that's what was
done here in these two series of papers
I'm going to say a little bit about the
2d construction but it was later
improved to 1d okay so they show that
determining the spectral gap so the
input to the problem now is a
Hamiltonian term so I'm describing it
using some number of bits and I'm
telling you here's the size of the
particles and here's the interaction
term described in a Hamiltonian matrix
and the name of the game is to know if I
were to apply that on the infinite grid
is that Hamiltonian gapless or does it
have a bounded spectral gap and they
prove that that's undecidable
um
so they actually reduce this to the
energetic energy density problem so it
really is the construction Billy is
about energy density so they show that
if you can compute the spectral graph
then you can compute the energy density
and then the hardness the difficulty of
the proof is really showing that the
energy energy density the density per
particle is hard to compute so it's hard
to determine if it's a constant or if
approaches zero from below
so
I'm short on time I'm just gonna say a
little bit I'm not gonna I'm gonna skip
over the reduction part and just say a
little bit about how the energy density
works so think of a reduction I'm I'm
reducing sort of decidability and so
ends my input and I want to say does the
universal Turing machine halts if it's
given and as the input that's an
undecidable problem and I'm translating
that into a Hamiltonian term okay and if
it halts then I'm gonna have an energy
density that's bounded below by a
constant if it doesn't halt then I'm
gonna have an energy density that's that
tends towards zero
underlying there so there's two levels
to this underlying this is sort of a
classical game of Wang tiles which is I
didn't put a date oh I did 61 so it's
it's sort of a an old problem where I'm
giving you a set of tiles and there are
costs for sitting putting certain colors
next to each other either above or below
in the horizontal direction or the
vertical direction and I'm asking you to
tile an N by n grid so as to minimize
the cost sort of a classic sort of
version of constraint satisfiability and
the construction makes use of a very
beautiful tiling construction on the
infinite grid that has whose lowest
whose minimum cost tiling has this very
beautiful a periodic structure and the e
periodic structure looks like this okay
so there are these exponentially sized
squares so each of these squares is of
dimension four to the K and the
frequency of the squares varies
inversely with the size so in the
infinite grid I have lots of these
little black squares and half as many of
these blue squares and half as many red
squares and each of these squares is
actually a little tile little square of
tiles so this was known before and they
use this as sort of the substrate to
their construction so a tile itself is
so a particle in this construction
itself has two components it tells you
what the tile is underneath and then
there's some sort of computational
process happening on top so if the
here's the picture here's the tiling and
sitting on top of it is some
computational process that were kind of
simulating on the boundary of these
squares okay
so the Hamiltonian encodes the input we
use the process that's taking place on
this this 1d line is we're going to
translate that N and write it in binary
and then we're gonna simulate the
universal Turing machine on that input
for some number of steps okay if we halt
there's a cost if we don't halt there's
no cost okay so basically if the
training the University of Turing
machine never caught halts there's no
costs on any of these squares but if it
does eventually halt at some finite
order decay it runs for a certain number
of steps for the decay if it does
eventually halt then all of those
squares from four to the K on up will
have a cost associated with it and that
will result in a constant cost over the
over the infinite grid so if it
eventually halts then there's a constant
cost and if not then it's zero so that's
how we get the differentiation
sort of
in a nutshell if the hurt universal
Turing machine halts in some finite
amount of time then the energy is
bounded below by some value because the
squares of that size on up incur some
cost and if it doesn't halt the minute
zero so a few things about directions we
still don't know how to actually
characterize the complexity of computing
translationally invariant
hamiltonians and the thermodynamic limit
so this result tells me it's undecidable
to tell if it's zero or some constant
but what if I wanted to compute that
constant is there a way to characterize
the complexity of that problem I'm not
even sure how to characterize it as a
complexity problem because for a given
Hamiltonian it's just a number so we
need some sort of even framework to even
get it in the framework of computational
complexity but we still don't know that
and that's really kind of at the end of
the day what many physicists are doing
when they're actually doing these
simulations this is what they want to
actually estimate is that this energy
density the next thing is that these
constructions they're obviously very
intricate and not probably not
particularly stable so if I have some
measure on hamiltonian terms if I tweak
it a little bit if I go epsilon away in
this in this space is it still hard is a
hard instance surrounded by easy
instances we don't know much about that
so that I think there are some
interesting directions to go with
respect to stability
obviously these are highly intricate
constructions that don't really
necessarily represent the physics seen
in nature so you could definitely ask
what about the common models that are
studied in physics
I'm gonna go quickly over a few things
to in order to get to some questions
again so one questions that be studied
is the bose hubbard model which i have
particles sort of hopping through the
system and child´s Gossett and Webb look
at this very classically studied natural
interaction on an arbitrary interaction
graph so we're kind of going in the
other direction I have a very simple
interaction term but now the input to
the problem is a graph and I I ask
what's the ground state of this
Hamiltonian if I apply this it's this
interaction term to every edge in a
graph and it's actually they in the in
the whelmed that they're looking at it's
actually equivalent to an XY model
another commonly studied problem
and it turns out that this problem is is
QA hard as well so this was later
improved their original construction had
self loops in the graph which is highly
non physical so there was a later
improvement with the construction that
didn't have these self loops which
actually corresponds nicely to the XY
model so the improvement kind of got rid
of those self loops which is a little
bit more natural but the interaction
graph is very complex okay because it's
it's it's encoding these kind of
computational gadgets in it
they mentioned new directions and sort
of playing with the Hamiltonian terms
for me the more interesting direction is
how can you simplify the graph can you
get a hardness result if your graph is
planar what if you have a grid and you
just have some subset of edges on the
grid is that hard is there a point at
which this problem becomes easy okay at
the end of the day physicists are just
looking at this on an N by n grid and I
don't even know how to again how to
frame that as a computational problem
because that's just a number again ok so
you've probably just converged
to some particular numbers and growth so
I'm not sure that there's a reasonable
way to to formulate this as a
computational problem but we don't have
a place where it actually gets easy
okay
I don't have time to cover this but
another family of results looks at the
opposite problem so I'm I'm giving you
qubit terms and you can you can have an
arbitrary interaction graph and any
scaling of those terms on the edges so I
give you some set of finite terms and
there's an analogous work to this in the
classical realm where I give you some
type of set of terms and I ask you if
you can apply scalings of these terms on
the edge of the graph what's the
complexity of that problem and it turns
out you can actually completely
characterize the complexity of these
terms into these different classes so at
some point they're P and P complete
stochastic and they complete and Q may
complete what's unphysical about this
model is that you can have negative and
positive coefficients which is typically
you only have positive coefficients or
negative coefficients arbitrary
interaction graph and then these large
coefficients because we're encoding a
computational problem in these in in
this interaction graph so and that was
later improved in a subsequent paper
where they look at let's say that you
just have positive coefficients on this
and again the space of two cubic terms
is sort of completely characterized in
terms of their complexity and then they
also look at 2d and the 2d grid and the
2d triangular grid and get qma
completeness results they're the most
interesting direction I think is to to
grapple with this idea that the the
coefficients themselves can be quite
large because so can you do this with
smaller coefficients
I'm gonna I I kind of want to end with
this this picture though so these are
the four classes that we that they can
categorize the complexity in what seems
to be missing from this picture and it's
curious to me that bqp is not here okay
and in all of the variations of local
Hamiltonian and there are gazillion I
haven't even talked about commuting case
or other cases I don't know of a single
instance or variety of the problem that
we can show is provably in bqp and not
known to be in P so you could concoct
one artificially if you think back to my
adiabatic picture I could imagine the
class of local animal Tony ins that are
the ground states of these propagation
hamiltonians where you have an input and
no witness that's gonna be bqp complete
but that's not a terribly natural
version of the problem I'm thinking in
terms and I wouldn't know how to encode
into the local Hamiltonian terms that
you don't have a witness so what I'm
thinking of is a local Hamiltonian term
I tell you tell me what the dimension of
the particles is you tell me the types
of interactions you can have between
these particles you define how they can
vary from edge to edge is it translation
in the environment is it not there's
another thing to vary the interaction
graph is it a grid is it an arbitrary
graph I don't know of a single way to
sort of define a problem that we know a
quantum computer can solve it where we
don't know that a classical computer can
solve it and I would think that quantum
computers should be useful I mean we
expect that quantum computers will be
useful in solving ground states I mean
I've talked about this this morning
they're in the process of working on
this in much the same way classical
computers are very useful a lot of the
time in solving np-hard problems but in
the classical world we have this
situation all the time where you have
some np-hard problem and you add a bunch
of constraints on it and all of a sudden
it falls into P but somehow in this
picture we start with the Q a complete
problem we start adding
straights to the point where you can no
longer encode boolean satisfiability and
it falls into P instead of B QP so
that's a little curious to me and it
would be interesting to know are there
sort of provable cases where quantum
computers are actually useful in solving
these these local Hamiltonian problems
we don't I I'm not aware now that I say
it in front of a room of 100 people
maybe five people will raise their hand
and tell me a counter example but I'm
not aware of an instance in which that's
the case so that's sort of interesting
it's interesting to me is there a way to
limit these so we can actually get a
quantum algorithm for them maybe it's
the lack of algorithmic techniques
maybe quantum computers aren't designed
for this particular type of optimization
problem I don't know the answer
[Applause]
have you thought of how to simulate open
quantum systems open as in so your
you've got it's connected to some bath
or something directly using semi-group
operators billions and there we're
looking for get states because they're
they're mixing with the bath said yeah I
mean there is a whole literature on
computing get states which I think would
probably speak to that more directly
probability distributions yes there
doesn't seem to be an analog in the
quantum set of workers who do the
analogous thing for the quantum in your
yeah so there's this beautiful quantum
metropolis algorithm we don't I don't
I'm not aware of much in the way that
proves convergence bounds for that or
for example C classes yeah so yeah I
don't know
if we take animal to nyan his ground
state and codes of factoring problem
wouldn't that be an example of the case
for which yeah and just like I said you
could imagine even a more generic case
where you have a the class of
Hamiltonians that just models whose
ground state models the evolution of a
circuit certainly that's bqp complete I
don't know how to describe that class in
sort of this local Hamiltonian framework
I mean I wouldn't know how to say you've
got these local Hamiltonian turns but
somehow you've got this construction
that doesn't when I define the local
Hamiltonian problem it doesn't say
anything about inputs or propagation or
witnesses or anything so you need some
way to define your class that that
disallows for this open witness in there
that makes it hard and I don't know of a
natural way to sort of define that in
sort of these local Hamiltonian terms so
you could certainly manufacture a
problem whose ground state is hard but
it's not it doesn't necessarily
naturally fit into this you know I give
you this set of terms and this set of
types of interactions
within this within these rules that
you've said for you know if you disallow
that that in fact as soon as you you
know yeah and I wonder if there's sort
of a general way of framing that problem
yeah I mean leave that company here I
was right they they have this flavor to
them once your allows sufficiently many
things and that's that's where you end
up so yeah I don't know exactly I mean
you have to sort of define the
parameters of your local Hamiltonian
problem appropriately in order to get
that but I feel like there's some
phenomenon like that happening here
[Applause]